نحن وسط مدينه هاتاي التي تتصدر قائمه
المدن والولايات التركيه الاكثر دماارا من
جراء الزلزال هذا هو المشهد هنا في هاتاي
فرق الانقاذ تتوافد وتعمل على مدار الساعه
تسابق الزمن بحثا عن ناجين هنالك ايضا من
يفترش الارض لانه فقد بيته ولم يعد يمتلك
اي شيء وهذه مساعدات تاتي الى هنا تباعا
من متبرعين ياتي المحتاج وياخذ ما يريد من
غذاء وطعام وحتى البس
وهنالك ايضا في المقابل عمليات بحث تجري
على مدار الساعه في كل لحظه بحثا عن ناجين
تحت الانقاض ومثال على هذا الذي يحدث هنا
في هاتاي ويتكرر في كل مكان هنا ما يحدث
في هذه البنايه حيث يتم البحث الان بعمليه
دقيقه وبطيئه عن شخص يعتقد انه لا يزال
على قيد الحياه تحت الانقاض امكانيات
بسيطه من بسبب
انتشار الدمار في كل مكان في هذه الولايه
ولكن مع بدء اليوم الثالث للزلزال الا
تزال محاولات العثور على الناجين مستمره
لقناتي العربيه والحدث عمار الهندي